you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme prince charles puts aside the
royal family's problems as he meets
aberdeenshire residents recovering from
the effects of storm arwen
heating down co2 down energy company eon
says sorry for sending customers socks
with a message to cut their carbon
footprint
strong winds and record-breaking
temperatures in argentina cause
wildfires to reignite leaving patagonia
in a state of emergency
and after cop 26 last november are
bigger nations following through on
their promises to help smaller countries
cope with the cost of climate change
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the spotlight on the royal family
after prince andrew was stripped of his
honorary titles hasn't stopped his elder
brother dealing with issues close to his
heart the prince of wales was out today
meeting residents in the northeast of
scotland who were involved in the clean
up operation of the area after storm
irwin last november between 500 000 and
a million trees were uprooted on the
haddo estate in aberdeenshire when winds
of up to 100 miles an hour struck prince
charles brushed aside questions about
his brother instead focusing on efforts
of the local community to restore the
area our correspondent james matthews
has more
hello i'm standing
where a tree once stood specifically
that tree it's one of an estimated
hundred thousand that were filled by
storm irwin
last november prince charles saw the
damage for himself today on a visit here
to the haddo country estate in ellen in
aberdeenshire his visit hosted by the
lord lieutenant of aberdeenshire and he
saw considerable damage and we can show
you some of the images here take a look
take a look left and look down the line
as far as the eye can see
and all you see is upturned uprooted
ancient woodland it is
one big mess caused by that 12-hour
storm that blew through the uk
specifically here in the northeast of
scotland
for 12 hours late last november prince
charles met people who were in the eye
of the storm
people who
were here they had the haddo head
gardener
people who were directly affected people
who lost power for several days 60 000
people in aberdeenshire
had their power cut off hundreds of
roads
were blocked to storm are when wreaked
its destructive power and you get a
sense if you look over there of the
of the power of nature the destructive
power of nature and prince charles saw
for himself
what it can do so a visit to to speak to
people involved to to lift the morale i
suppose of
individuals communities people who are
helping communities get back together
after the destructive power of storm
irwin and also a visit to
to satisfy his interest in nature and
nature's impact
now many leaders of developing nations
left cop feeling disappointed that they
didn't witness bigger commitments from
the wealthy nations to do more to
address climate change for many the
crisis is a lot more than a threat
they're already living with the
consequences of global warming and while
they contribute the least to the problem
they are paying a high price so despite
being responsible for less than one
percent of global carbon emissions small
island developing states are on the
front line of climate change
some nations have been left in debt from
dealing with increasing climate impacts
such as extreme weather for example in
2017 dominica lost 226 of its gdp to the
impacts of hurricane maria
it's why at cop 26 countries and small
islands called on wealthier nations to
meet their pledge on climate finance and
pledge to provide a hundred billion
dollars every year to fund mitigation
and adaptation now this pledge was
missed and it won't be met until
2023 well joining me now to tell us more
is the founder of island innovation
james ellsmore so welcome to you and
let's start with the money how important
is that climate finance a hundred
billion dollars promised in 2009
won't be forthcoming until 2023
how important is it to those vulnerable
nations and what's its delay meant
that money is absolutely vital um i
would argue that 100 100 billion that
was promised was not really sufficient
in the first place it's a quite a round
number and a lot of the the quality of
the money that's already been received
has been made in the form of loans um
which add to this issue of debt but
obviously as has already been mentioned
small island developing states are the
most vulnerable to climate change as are
many other developing nations and they
are not the people they're not the
countries that are causing the issue and
so for me there's a moral imperative for
wealthier nations to help finance the
adaptation um
for these islands to um avoid the worst
impacts of climate change for their
populations well yes because what
exactly is the money intended for is it
about them moving away from fossil fuels
or is it about that adaptation that you
talk about
well there's two parts there's the
mitigation and the adaptation and often
those things um are part and parcel of
the same thing for example renewable
energy
projects could be both mitigation
reducing carbon emissions but also
adaptation
helping to make those countries less
vulnerable to impacts of climate change
projects such as sea walls um to protect
from uh hurricanes will be considered
adaptation so there's a whole range of
different um different projects that
impact food security water
energy et cetera et cetera that this
money needs to go to to really ensure
that climate change um
climate change will impact these
countries but it's to reduce the level
of impact and ultimately the impact on
human lives in those countries
and what about the area of loss and
damage because there are a number of
countries who say we've already suffered
damage and we think that those most
polluting countries should be the ones
to pay for it have they made any
progress with that argument
absolutely um
there's this widespread argument that um
the most polluting countries should be
paying for vulnerable countries there
was some progress at cop um it was not
nearly enough and what i think will be
interesting the year ahead as the uk
hands over its presidency to egypt which
is itself a developing nation itself an
extremely vulnerable nation to climate
change
if that will shift the narrative and the
emphasis that we see as we move towards
cop 27 later this year there were
important commitments made such as the
infrastructure for brazilian island
states fund the uk government
contributed a total of 10 million to
that fund there was also the small
island developing states capacity and
resilience program which the uk
government contributed a further 40
million pounds to but in the grand
scheme of things these are quite small
uh quite small numbers and what is the
concern by many countries is not just
that the money is not reaching them but
the quality of the funding and the
limitations or the forms that that
funding is taking is not adequate well
james elmore very interesting to talk to
you thanks very much indeed
thank
you so in today's other climate news
energy company eon has apologized for
sending out socks to customers 30 000
households received the gift which was
labeled with the tagline heating down
co2 down it comes as charities warn a
further 2 million households will face
fuel poverty as energy bills increase
the company claimed the socks were
designed to lower consumers carbon
footprint and said we're incredibly
sorry for how we've made some of our
customers feel
environmental groups are calling for
greater transparency from the indonesian
government after a study found that
forest fires burned nearly twice as much
land as was officially reported the
study published in the earth systems
science data journal found 3.1 million
hectares were burned in 2019 an area
bigger than belgium compared to 1.6
million hectares reported by the
forestry ministry
a double paralympic gold medalist has
been jailed for a year for super gluing
himself to a plane during an extinction
rebellion protest the disruption caused
by james brown of exeter in devon cost
british airways around 40 000 pounds
in his defense brown had claimed that he
had to do something spectacular to draw
attention to the climate crisis
and strong winds and unseasonably high
temperatures have reignited wildfires in
patagonia in argentina temperatures of
45 degrees have led to tinder dry
conditions and smoke from the fires has
already caused the closure of the
country's longest highway a state of
emergency has been declared over fear
that the wildfires could spread as
quickly as they did last year
now the world's first fossil free
nitrogen fertilizers could soon be
available to the agriculture industry
the new fertilizer is made using
renewable energy and is expected to
reduce the carbon footprint of the
product by up to 90 percent the chief
executive of the fertilizer company yara
explained how it works
yara is
already producing some of the lowest
carbon footprint fertilizer in the world
today and
but still we're using natural gas to
produce that fertilizer and by changing
the method to produce the fertilizer to
renewable power we're able to reduce the
footprint of that fertilizer by another
80 to 90 is really groundbreaking
changes
plants just like us humans need the
nutrition
and one of the key nutrients is nitrogen
and there are two ways to produce that
one is to use fossil
fuel and
the other one is to use renewable energy
to produce green hydrogen and turn it
into ammonia and in turn turn it into
fertilizer and that's what we're doing
here and producing fertilizer with the
renewable energy
with food representing 25 to 30 of
global greenhouse gas emissions we're
not going to be able to reach the paris
agreement unless we're able to solve
food and to decarbonize food
by providing products to the farmers
that help them to reduce the carbon
footprint but at the same time
to develop a market where the low carbon
products are also
appreciated and paid for we can help the
farmers to do what's good for the planet
but also help them with their income
just to let you know in the latest
episode of the weekly climate show our
asia correspondent tom cheshire gets up
close and personal with china's booming
elephant population let's take a
look the most memorable moment was
definitely getting head-butted by long
long
uh we were walking along the path and as
he came up he was giving me a sort of
inquisitive push to start with am i
being attacked
but what became a headlong charge i'm
not sure what the etiquette is i mean
he's only a baby elephant so i don't
think he can really push back but on the
other hand he is 300 kilograms
he's an abandoned baby elephant very
very curious he just goes around
munching absolutely everything because
he's trying to find out about the world
he was found with his leg trapped and
taken to a rescue center in sichuan
banner south west china
a must-watch there now do stay tuned
because coming up next i'll be joined by
climate justice activist daisy gargi and
michael jacobs professor of political
economy at the university of sheffield
and we're going to be discussing what
progress has been made on climate
finance for small nations and if the
royals are climate leaders
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate justice activist daisy gargi and
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield michael jacobs
so very good evening to both of you nice
to see you though
now earlier on the show we heard how
small island nations are seeing the very
real effects of climate change right now
scientists have warned that time is
running out as rising sea levels
disrupted weather patterns and coastal
erosion threaten the island's futures
well at cop26 world leaders promise to
help climate vulnerable countries cope
with the crisis so what progress has
been made michael to you first of all
one big area of contention of course is
that 100 billion dollars a year promised
back in 2009 still not forthcoming
how important are those funds and did
cop make any difference in getting the
money together
well they're very important as you heard
from uh your previous contributor
um for many of the poorest countries in
the world
it is support from uh outside that will
add to the resources they are providing
themselves both to cut their own
emissions um but much more importantly
to adapt
to climate change um that they're
already experiencing and you know every
day there's some new report of
of some extreme weather event or some
high effects of higher temperatures um
which the least uh well-off countries in
the world experienced uh the worst and
of course they're the countries which
have least contributed to the climate
problem so this is a question of climate
justice as many of them
have very powerfully said and cop 26
didn't really make any progress on this
the commitment to provide 100 billion
dollars a year was first made in 2009
not just in the paris agreement in 2015
uh and that was meant to be achieved by
2020 uh it hasn't been the new date that
uh it is expected to be uh provided by
is 2023.
um one of the things the developing
countries asked for in uh glasgow cop 26
was that uh if it wasn't going to be
reached for 2023 then the figure
on average over the period 2020 to 2025
would total 500 billion uh which meant
that more money should be given in 2024
in 2025 that was not agreed so i think
many developing countries particularly
the small island states left glasgow
feeling very very disappointed they also
asked for uh
for a
contributions to start being made from
the richer countries for loss and damage
that's the actual loss and damage they
experienced from climate change um that
was not agreed they just got some new
talks so really very little progress was
made in glasgow and of course since then
it's been it's too early to say uh
what's happening since then but there
are big expectations that more money
will be committed to this year and we
need to see some of that beginning to
emerge in the debates in developed
countries well yes and days i can see
you nodding there but what about the
year ahead because one of the the pluses
of cop 26 was this agreement to come
back at cop27 you know just in one year
rather than in five years with new
targets new commitments new pressure so
do you have some confidence that that
could benefit these smaller nations in
need of support
commitments are great but when they're
not followed through what do they mean
they mean nothing um you've already said
that it's been over a decade and we are
still yet to see the money that's needed
desperately by vulnerable countries all
across the world i think there needs to
be this recognition that as
a country who has contributed a large
amount to the exploitation of the
natural world but then also carbon
emissions we hold a responsibility to do
our best to support countries who are
going through literally the mess that we
have created and i don't think that
there is enough like i don't think
there's enough energy that's being put
into that at the moment well yes and
michael to go back to your point about
loss and damage as well because as you
say these countries that have
contributed the least to climate change
have already suffered many of them
suffered a lot of damage and they feel
that the owners should be on the richer
nations to pay for that um are they
getting anywhere on that you say no
progress at cop26 but is that argument
being heard out there do you think
um it's being uh it's being heard it's
in the world it's much more live now
than it used to be
because it's being experienced you can
see that loss and that and the damage
now in many
countries of which the small island
states are many of the most vulnerable
one of the most interesting ideas that
was put forward at
cop26 in glasgow was from the barbadian
prime minister that the global
currency that is issued
on occasion by the international
monetary fund the imf um so-called
special drawing rights or sdrs is a
little bit complicated but you can think
of it as a kind of global reserve
currency that money should specifically
be released by the international
monetary fund for climate uh development
in climate ah compatible development in
the worst affected countries including
for loss and damage
that idea which was raised as i say by
the barbadian prime minister
in a very powerful speech at the opening
session of cop 26
could get i think some legs this year um
it's unlikely i think to be done this
year but i think you could see many
developing countries getting behind that
proposal and because it's a way of
providing new money
it's something which uh i think many
developed countries in the end might say
yes this is something we should look at
okay and it would provide money
successively over several years and
that's the important thing okay an
interesting one to watch that one
michael we're going to move on to our
next topic though now and from launching
the earthshot prize to calling out
leaders at cop 26 the royal family is
often praised for speaking up on climate
change but critics say their support for
the green movement doesn't go far enough
they argue the monarchy has failed to
use its power and influence to encourage
real change at home and across the world
so is britain's most famous family doing
enough to tackle the crisis so days
prince charles has been campaigning on
the environment for decades hasn't he
prince william increasingly engaged and
we even heard the queen call for action
at cop26 so what's your take are they
doing enough
so my take is that this is extremely
convenient timing um to be talking about
the climate crisis when the royal family
is becoming more and more irrelevant in
public life um so i am highly critical
of the advances towards helping the
environmental movement especially given
that they are the biggest landowner in
the uk like one of the biggest
landowners in the uk and we are still
yet to see rewilding efforts on their
land and we're still yet to see land
being returned back to commoners from
when they originally were taken um these
are the kind of dramatic acts that we
need to reverse climate change in the
way that we're facing and i'm not seeing
that kind of like deliverables from the
royal family and um to talk specifically
about prince williams who has said some
very controversial things around
overpopulation rather than ignoring the
the like the actual problem is that we
consume too much and we have become too
um too used to living these really high
carbon lifestyles and what we need to do
is reduce this he doesn't talk about the
role that corporations are playing in
the destruction of our earth but instead
he focuses on
pollution population and population of
countries for example in the global
south who actually emit far less than
the average european country so i think
it's a little bit ridiculous quite
frankly okay that's interesting and i
know that prince charles has addressed
the issue of corporations getting on
board i think and michael um some would
say he's been campaigning for decades
his first speech on the environment was
in 1970 i think about 50 years ago
prince william's got his earth shot
prize handing out million pound prizes
so what what do you think do you agree
with days or do you think they are
making a tangible difference to people's
opinions
uh i don't know whether they're making a
tangible difference i'm sure there are
some people who are followers of
admirers of the royal family who may
receive the climate message from them in
uh in their reading or their
understanding of what prince charles and
prince william are saying and i suppose
if they're saying it and people some
people are listening to them then that's
a good thing it's raising awareness
amongst people who might not otherwise
get it they're not of course political
players their words don't really have
very much impact among governments
it's governments that speak to other
governments and not uh heads of state uh
who are merely ceremonial um i do think
it's uh the points that days makes are
legitimate if you are a public figure
you do need to be speaking on the things
that you have some control over and they
are
as she says landowners and so that's a
that's a really critical i think part of
their commitment if they are to be
making it but you know like other
celebrities
in the end if they speak about something
and it reaches some people that's good
um but it's uh governments and it's
public policies that really matter and
we shouldn't be distracted i think by uh
what they say when we're looking at the
politics we must leave it i can see days
nodding on that note of agreement we
will wrap things up and end the week on
on the pair of you nodding so daisy
gargie and michael jacobs thank you both
very much indeed for your time
so that's everything from us for today
but do you remember to listen to our
podcast climate cast and this week we
explore if germany is a climate leader
or a climate villain and that's
available now wherever you normally get
your podcast from thanks for watching
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you